meanwhile jamie lee curtis is a proud
supporter of the trans community
revealing she's become a grateful
student to her transgender daughter ruby
speaking with people the pair are
opening up about the journey their
families on together in the new issue on
newsstands nationwide friday ruby says
she was scared to come out but she knew
her parents would be supportive saying
it was intimidating but i wasn't worried
they had been so accepting of me my
entire life jamie admits that learning
new terminology and words has been
challenging at times telling the outlet
it's speaking a new language i'm new at
it i'm not someone who is pretending to
know much about it and i'm going to blow
it i'm going to make mistakes i would
like to try and avoid making big
mistakes
the halloween kills actor says she's
become more thoughtful over time and
admits she does mess up adding but if
one person reads this sees a picture of
ruby and me and says i feel free to say
this is who i am then it's worth it
and jamie proudly shares the interview
via social media with the caption
helping others is something everyone
should do i don't think it's only our
household thing it should be a human
thing ruby i am proud to be your mother
today more than ever
[Music]